[Music]
[Music]
hey listen bill cosby first of all
is my you know he's my hero as a kid
because i always wanted to be like him
and uh i got his albums tried to emulate
him
and but i didn't like his stand-up but i
like
the way he was as a man
because this was before they didn't say
he was a rapist on the [ __ ]
liner notes of the albums you know
as my buddy says the worst part about
cosby was he was a hypocrite and i said
i don't think that was the worst part
to be the worst part of the raping
way up high
and then the second would be the
drugging
then the third would be the scheming
but anyways hypocrisy would be way
[ __ ] down the lie you know
like on the fourth page or some [ __ ]
like i'm no expert but i think probably
uh
most uh rapists are hypocrites
but that still doesn't diminish how how
wonderful this is a wonderful
wonderful thing to be included with some
of my
my heroes richard pryor and george
carlin
and karl reiner and
lily tomlin who else got this bill bill
has one of these
[Applause]
did y'all make bill give his back
no because i know there was a big outcry
from people that was trying to get bill
to give his trophies back
you know you that when they want you to
give your trophies back
[Applause]
trophy back too he should do one show we
just come out and just talk
crazy now i would like to talk
to some of the people
who feel that i should give
back my toys
just because you may have heard
recently that i allegedly
put the pill into people's chocolate
i wish somebody would come up to my
house talking about give up the trophy
because you put the pill in the paper
chocolate you get
cause i'm not giving back
[Applause]
and who
who is hannibal barris
[Laughter]
first of all hannibal is a caveman's
name
and you're gonna just come on out and
pull pushed over the apple cart that had
if i ever see or meet this
hannibal embarrassing person i am going
to try to kill this [ __ ]
just one show like this just do one like
that but like i said i don't want to go
too far and bill
i think bill cosby's the biggest
comedian of all time oh do you yeah
yeah i don't think anyone will ever
match his
production and quality of material
do you like bill cosby i love bill cosby
yeah did you listen to those records
when you were a kid sure
it was so great to see and i know
everybody's bust your balls when are you
going to do stand up but i was it wasn't
really doing stan
it was like a long acceptance you did
part of it
yes it was an acceptance speech but you
did your great bill cosby impersonation
and it's a crazy bill cosby
impersonation it's like bill cosby if
it was probably like bill cosby in the
playboy mansion you know
uh what was really going on but did you
hear from bill
at all after that oh no oh no no
is that why you don't have a computer
you might get an email from bill cosby
dude do you know when i was in
i was in nashville this past weekend and
i was sitting there
watching the news during the day and
they just go like
um oh and folks if you're in the
downtown area
and you see the police doing something
that seems a little disturbing
don't worry it's just an exercise and
then they continued on
and it was just like you didn't do any
follow-up like or there's no more
information
an exercise what are they practicing for
that whatever they're doing is
is like scary now i'm not saying they're
going to come at us is it some sort of
anti-terrorism thing i have no [ __ ]
idea what it was but like just the
the kind of vagueness that they dude
right before the dodgers scored the
other day uh
npr my wife listens to that [ __ ] and i
you know
morning becomes eclectic if you enjoy
this show
fresh air with terry gross yeah there's
always those pauses
now joe when you first started doing
stand up you know what i think of
i've discussed this before but it's kind
of important you know what i think of
when i think of those people
do you know what that guy john gomeshi
is i like npr but it's so easily to be
made fun of it's it's easy to drive off
the road into a [ __ ] tree when you're
listening to it too
oh yeah now there's a lot of uh droning
on
which nobody does that really super
sensitive left-wing style of talk
the guy that was uh he did that really
well the main guy that did that was this
guy john gomeshi
who was on cbc in canada and it turned
out he liked to
beat the [ __ ] out of girls when he was
having sex with them he would punch them
in the face and club them in the head
and it was crazy [ __ ]
and one girl came out yeah yeah one and
he would do it without asking him it was
like
you know like you know that's a strong
move it's
chris strong move in the wreck well i
mean who knows who's telling the truth
because he was kind of acquitted of a
lot of it
it was it's it's because it was very
difficult to find but does he have the
money to get acquitted
you know well that's true that's a good
point but he was fired and there was a
gang of girls that came out and said he
used to beat them up
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait the gal does the interviews yeah
that talks like this bill burr so tell
me
how he just bugged me one time when i'm
not saying all the i don't know what the
[ __ ] he does in his personal life but uh
russell peters was on there
and he just goes like he's like russell
you have
nine cars and russell's like yeah and he
goes
why and it's just [ __ ] like making
him feel bad because he's doing well
he's you know and then russell had to
[ __ ] basically justify it and come up
with money
and now i can have it i'm sorry i
[ __ ] made it
wow and i like cars wow yeah
so no i'm not saying he's a [ __ ] that's
just saying just this
right there well even right there that
bugged me i hate when people [ __ ] do
stuff like he had to hit somebody
if you get like eight or nine chicks
they're saying you beat the [ __ ] out of
why you're having sex yeah
even if you get it what if somebody got
cracked what is your number that
innocent
until guilty or how many accusations
bill cosby i gave in around
30 30
i heard the first couple but we had
heard that right
around seven yeah no i i there was
rumors of
his infidelity but yes i i never heard
of uh
you never heard that no i did i heard
that i had heard that it was like a
rumor it was a rumor that he would drug
women
it was a rumor a long time ago he was uh
there was a court case
that is part of this case from i believe
it was like 2005
and that was one of the reasons why they
weren't allowed to admit that evidence
because the judge had made a decision
that if he paid this woman off
then it couldn't be admissible in a
future trial but it was all verbal they
didn't get anything on paper
so once they found out they didn't get
this on paper they're like well we're
going to admit this and then the woman
came out and then he sued the woman that
he gave the money to
for drugging her and the whole thing is
very very sordid
but with bill cosby i think it's up to
like 50 or something crazy yeah so you
got to wonder out of those 50
there's probably like 12 that are just
crazy like he drugged me too
you know but the fact that but the fact
that he'd still be over 30. it's just
nuts you and i were supposed to go see
bill cosby in vegas we had made like
we were talking about doing it but we
both flaked and we never wound up doing
it and that's one of my main regrets to
this day
i would have liked to see him before the
stink hit him i did i saw it right
before
i met him and then three months later i
saw him
do you remember when he was doing shows
still like all those women were coming
out he was still doing shows
like he was still doing shows he was
like [ __ ] it i'm still doing him
and he went out and he still did those
shows for a little while i thought i
think he thought he was powerful enough
to just sort of ignore it and then it
wasn't gonna
uh it wasn't gonna come around but dude
i gotta tell you if you gave me a
thousand guests not a thousand but if
you gave me 200 guesses his name would
not be on that
out of all the [ __ ] of all the [ __ ]
people like if you said okay
this there's a comic out there doing
this [ __ ] really you got your top 20
where you'd be like oh yeah
you know what i didn't i never heard the
rumors i did hear the rumors and also
there was a time am i not in the
clubhouse
how am i a comedian this long and i'm
not [ __ ] here in the room i heard it
from hollywood people i didn't hear it
from comics i heard it from people in
the business i heard it from like actors
and from people that like work on tv
show sets i heard it during the news
radio days
i had heard it yeah he was doing it at
the show
he was doing it for two people that were
on the show
to people allegedly who the [ __ ] knows
but there's something
it was something unbelievable
unbelievably creepy
but after the accusations came out when
he was still doing shows
he would go on stage with one eye
looking to the left one eye looking
straight
he developed a dead eye somewhere along
the line right so he'd go on stage with
that weird uh
kind of some slack he's like 90. i know
i'm david for the grace of god but he's
dying right i mean that's my point it's
like things are falling off the wheels
right the wheels are falling off the the
ride
and he's got this shirt on this sweater
on it says hello friend
and he's he's on stage and he walks out
there and
and everybody's clapping and cheering
and some guy's yelling
you're a rapist you're a rapist
and then you know they grab the guy and
shuffle him out and then people going we
love you bill
and he just doesn't even acknowledge
he's like just ignore them just ignore
them yeah
it was something crazy about that it was
like the last
the last sparks before they threw the
water on the fires like there was just
a little hope like a gas you've got some
embers last spark before they took the
gas
i mean his career i mean his life they
threw water on him like i mean he's just
it's over like no one's gonna go see him
live now right i mean it's kind of over
doesn't water put out the sparks yes
that's what i mean they threw the water
on them
they said no i mean like he had a moment
of like there was still some sparks oh
oh okay
the accusations came out but he was
still doing these shows and people still
came out they're like we love you bill
he's got this you gotta explain
it wasn't a good analogy here comes the
kicker you ready
here's the fact that i heard but haven't
confirmed i heard
that when martin luther king stood on
the steps of the lincoln memorial and
said he had a dream
he was speaking into a pa system that
bill
cosby paid for do you understand what
i'm saying
the point is this he rapes but he saves
and he saves more than he rapes but he
probably does break
thank you very much good night